DRUMMOND'S STRENGTHS RIGHT
THERE.
HE'S GOT VERY QUICK HANDS.
HE STUNTED AT DURANT, TRIED TO
GET BACK TO THE ROLLING LaMARCUS
ALDRIDGE OFF THAT PINDOWN.
DURANT LEADING THE BREAK.
AND HORTON-TUCKER WITH THE FOUL,
BLOCKING FOUL, THEY SAY BEFORE
THE SHOT.
THAT'S TWO FOULS ON
HORTON-TUCKER.
>> Mark: LOOK AT THE FINISH BY
IRVING.
I SAY THIS, TAKING THE DEFENSE
FOR A WIN, ARE NOW IN A
POSITION TO MAKE THIS A VERY,
VERY HE LONG NIGHT FOR THE
BROOKLYN NETS.
>> Ian: WESTBROOK IS NOW 7 OF
11 FROM THE FIELD.
TOOKETTE OUT ON THE RIM AND
THE WIZARDS.
FOUL CALLED.
HACHIMURA HITS THE DECK.
>> Richard: OH, GIVE ME THE
REPLAY.
HE GOES AROUND TWO, AND DUNKS
ON THE THIRD.
OH, COME ON.
YOU GOT
IMPRESSIVENESS WITH THE
FINISH.
>> Ian: DEROZAN STRIPPED OF
THE BALL BY SHAMET CLEAN.
THE NETS FORCE THE TURNOVER.
HARDEN, OH WHAT A BOUNCE FORH
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ANOTHER
HIGHLIGHT, INSTEAD GRIFFIN IS
GOING TO THE FREE THROW LINE.
>> Sarah: THIS IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY FILTHY.
THROUGH FOUR PLAYERS, RIGHT
IN SIDE, THE  JORDAN AGAINST
HUNTER.
KICKOUT, COLLINS SHORT.
REBOUND CONTROLLED BY DURANT.
NETS RUNNING THE FLOOR HARD.
DURANT, LEAD, IRVING, OH THE
ENGLISH!
HE P THE SCOOP.
A FOUL ON COLLINS.
>> SARAH: AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
A FINISH HERE BY THE NETS.
AND KYRIE IRVING UP, UNDER,
HIGH OFF THE GLASS FROM THE
OPPOSITE SIDE.
>> IAN: THAT'S ASTOUNDING!
>> IT IS.
LOOK AT THIS.
JUST HANG--
NIGHT.
>> Grant: THAT WAS A THROWBACK
DUNK RIGHT THERE FROM BLAKE.
>> Marv: GIANNIS FOR THREE.
0 FOR 3.
FROM DOWNTOWN.
THE OTHER NIGHT.
HERE'S DURANT.
CROSSOVER ON GIANNIS AND HITS!
PLUS THE FOUL.
>> Grant: CROWD IS GETTING INTO
IT BUT HUSTLE PLAYS, GRIFFIN
CONTINUES WITH THAT PERFORMANCE.
GREAT ANTICIPATION.
GREAT LIFT FOR THE OLD
LEONARD, SECOND ATTEMPT.
IT'S A ONE POINT GAME.
NETS FIND THEMSELVES IN
ANOTHERPOTENTIALLY HAIRY
SITUATION.
HARDEN GOES LONG.
GREEN, BALL FAKE AND IT'S GOOD,
A FOUL WITH 5.5 HARDEN THROWS
THE TOUCHDOWN PASS TO JEFF
GREEN.
TALK ABOUT REDEMPTION.
BROOKLYN IN THE SAME POSSESSION
THEY ARE IN.
TWO NIGHTS AGO.
JEFF GREEN, WIDE OPEN AND YOU
LOOK LIKE HE DID NOT EVEN REALLY
WANT TO SHOOT THAT RIGHTHINK OF
BOSTON, 2008.
THEY GOT LIGHTNING IN A BOTTLE
AND THEY WON IT ALL.
YOU THINK OF THE HEAT'S FIRST
YEAR WITH THEIR BIG THREE.
THEY LOST TO DALLAS IN THE NBA
FINALS, AMONGST OTHER
ILLUSTRATIONS AND CONTROL AN
OFFENSE.
GETS YOU SINGLE HANDEDLY IN THE
GAME.
THE GUY IS BRILLIANT.
>> WHISTLE AND A FOUL.
HE CONTINUES TO DO WELL ON THE
OFFENSIVE GLASS.
>> I DNT OFFENSE.
SARA: INSTANT OFFENSE AND HE
IS NOT AFRAID TO LET IT FLY.
IAN: 11 SECOND DIFFERENCE,
SHOT CLOCK TO GAME CLOCK.
DOTSON LOSES IT, WALKING THE
TIGHTROPE.
OH!
WADE GRIFFIN, RAZZLE DAZZLE.
OH, NEXT LEVEL.
KEVIN DURANT, THE RACK ATTACK,
AND ONE OF THEG.
IT'S DURANT THIS TIME, BUT
THIS MAY BE THE PLAY OF THE
YEAR IN THE REGULAR SEASON
FINALE, RAZZLE DAZZLE, FLAVOR,
AND BRINGING THE SPIKE.
THIS IS JUST TOO GOOD,
ASTONISHING.GREEN!
HE HAD CRUEL INTENTIONS.
[LAUGHTER].
PATTY MILLS MISSES FROM
THREE-POINT TERRITORY AND
CLAXTON THE REBOUND, GETS RID
OF IT QUICKLY FOR HARDEN.
>> Sarah: I DID SEE THAT
MOVIE, A COUPLE OF TIMES.
>> Ian: YOU DID?
REESE WITHERSPOON.
OH, THE JUMPER GOES, JAMES
HARDEN AND THE FOUL!
.
>> Sarah: OH IT'S GETTING TOO
GOOD HERE.
LOOK AT THIS, THE STEP  GET TE
OR THE RIM.
>> Marv: ALL RIGHT.
JEFF GREEN GETS IT INTO DURANT,
AND HE IS ON TUCKER AND HE TURNS
AND SHOOTS AND YES!
WITH ONE SECOND REMAINING.
ONE SECOND LEFT.
DURANT HITS A THREE!
MILWAUKEE HAS ONE TIME-OUT, AND
THEY CALL FOR TIME-OUT.
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE SHOT BY KEVIN
DURANT.
>> Referee: WE WILL REVIEW IT
FOR A THREE.
THE REPLAY IS CONFIRMED, IT IS A
THREE-POINT FIELD GOAL.
>> Grant: HE GATHERS THE FEET,
AND THE QUESTION IS IF THE TOE
IS ON THE LINE, AND IT IS
LOOKING LIKE ON THE ANGLE, IT
WAS ON THE LINE, BUT STILL IT IS
A BEAUTIFUL SHOT FROM DURANT.
OFF BALANCE FADING AWAY, AND
TUCKER WAS IN HIS FACE, AND ABLE
TO CONCENTRATE AND STEP UP, AND
KNOCK DOWN THAT SHOT, BUT FROM
THAT ANGLE, MARV, IT LOOKED LIKE
DEFINITELY THE TOE WAS ON THE
LINE, AND DEPENDING